(bird screeches)
MAN:
Kingdoms will fall.
##
-(screeching)
-Heroes will rise.
And a great warrior
shall emerge...
armed only with his courage
and his weapon of war.
-Ah! Poppy! Come on!
-(bell rings)
You gotta keep the wing level,
otherwise its gonna look fake!
I'm not an animatronic expert,
Ian.
I'm a game programmer.
I shouldn't be doing
any of this.
Well, you can thank David
for that.
He's the one that wanted
to save money.
No. No. I just didn't want
to spend $5 million on a promo.
Frankly, I think this whole
thing is confusing.
Do you guys have
any idea what a raven
flying through the landscape
is supposed to look like?
-What? No. Of course not.
-I've never seen a raven.
You know what's gonna sell it?
I should take my shirt
completely off and get
super greased up.
-What does that have
to do with the videogame?
-That's not what he's saying.
-Well, that'll sell the reality.
-What reality?
Of a man on a bird?
##